اليوم السعوديه عندها مشروع واضح ومهم جدا
في جانب همم تنشيط السياحه واستقطاب
السياح وفي جانب جذب الاستثمارات الاجنبيه
همم الى البلد هل يمارس السفير والسفاره
الدور في الجانبين في استراتيجيات معينه
لكل اتجاه كل دوله وايش الفرص اللي احنا
نرغب فيه تعزيزها مع هذه الدوله وكيف نبغى
نعزز هذه الفرص هذه ترسل لكم طبعا طبعا
طيب اذا هي لكم ليش ما صار شيء يعني على
هذا السياق من ناحيه جذب الاستفارات
اجنبيه او اقامه او المشاركه في المعارض
بالسياحه السويديين اذا ذكرت على رقم سبعه
الاف سائح سويدي فقط
وزاره السعوديه
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه وانا عم اجريسي
استضيف قاعده التحول وقاده الاعمال وقاده
الراي وسولف معهم على المستجدات رؤيه
السعوديه 20 30
اليوم غير اعتياديه لان لاول مره ركب ضيف
من القطاع الدبلوماسي
الشهوان سفيره خادم الحرمين الشريفين لدى
مملكه السويد والجمهوريه ايسلندا تكلمنا
عن مسيرتها بشكل شخصي وايش اللي دخلها في
قطاع
الدبلوماسي في الفتره اللي ما كانت همم
المراه متاح لها مثل هذه الفرس بشكل سلس
وبعدين تكلمنا عن تدرج الوظيفي والوصول
للقياده همم
البعثه الدبلوماسيه والعمل الكسيره همم في
في هذه الدول وتكلمنا على دور السفير بشكل
عام ايش اهم المسؤوليات اللي عليه ايش
الخطوط الحمراء اللي يفترض انه ما همم
يعني يتجاوزها هل يفترض ان يكون جريب جدا
من المجتمع او يجب انه يحذر من انه يكون
قريب حتى لا يقع في بعض الاخطاء لتتحول
الى ازمات دبلوماسيه ايش يعني سحب السفير
ايش يعني طرد السفير اااممم
كيف يتم بناء العلاقه داخل المجتمع اللي
السفير يكون موجود فيه بعدين تكلمنا بشكل
عام على
الهجمات اللي تواجهها السعوديه من بعض دول
مجتمع الغربي همم واللي تعتبر احيانا تدخل
في شؤون همم السعوديه الداخليه فا ايش دور
السفير في التعامل مع مثل هذه التحديات
بعدين دخلنا على همم البلد نفسه همم تعمل
فيه ضيفه واللي هو دوله او مملكه السويد
تحدثنا عن البلد همم المجتمع همم اهم سمات
هذا مش تمام وبعد ختمنا بالمجموعه من
اسئلتكم الثمينه
مثل هل يقوم السفير بتسويق فرص استثماريه
وتسويق السياحه للبلد
هل هناك مشاكل مرتبطه بنمط حياه السفير مع
اسرته اسئله مثل ليش ايسلنت خضراء وجرين
لاند اا شهبه على على سؤال احد الاصدقاء
همم
وايش يعني ايش اكثر الاشياء التي تتمنى
السفيره انها تاخذها من السويد او المجتمع
السويد وتنقل هذه السعوديه الى اخر
اسئلتكم الثمينه فتركم مع الحوار حياك
الله وفيصل شرفتيني ونورتينا شكرا لك
وفيصل وش قصه رحله الضياع
هتطلع
صح
[ضحك]
هذه الرحله اللي قاعد فيها سبع ساعات
ضايعين ههه
[ضحك]
احد الانشطه الممتعه جدا الواحد ممكن
يسويها في السويد
يعني صراحه متقدمه جدا فيها تعليمات وفيها
همم يعني علامات عشان الطريق وخدمات والى
اخره فهمم انا بطبيعتي احب الطبيعه واحب
اتمشى في همم
واحده من السيارات اللي كانوا عائلتي
زوجتي
لهم رحله في منطقه تقريبا
خمسه تقريبا
[موسيقى]
اكل للاسف فعلا
في ناس كثير طبعا ما في خطر انك انت تضيعي
هناك وفي ارقام ننزل او لا سمح الله
الواحد فعلا ما اعرف يطلع من المكان الي
هو فيه بس الرحله بدل ما تكون ساعتين
للاسف فعلا تحولت الى تقريبا اكثر من ست
ساعات واصبحت ذكرى جميله بصراحه
لنا لنا جميعا الاولاد فيها تحديات كانت
في مسارات كانت صعبه لازم تتصدق اماكن او
تنزل من اماكن الى اخره المناظر كانت
خلابه وجميل
يعني مسار كده همم نهري قريب من التراك او
المسار اللي احنا نمشي فيه جميله خالص
ههه همم احنا سعداء جدا باصرافكم فيصل فهل
فهل الحلقه بصفتك سفيره خادم الحرمين
الشريفين في مملكه السويد وجرين لاند اااه
يعني هي من اول او هي اول حرفين اول حلقه
نكسب فيها ضيف من السلك الدبلوماسي
ولذلك متحمسين اننا نستغلها في ايضا
التنوير ببعض المفاهيم الدبلوماسيه ببعض
الادوار اللي يقوم بها السفير والسفاره
همم وهنبداها بالتدرج فاحنا احنا اول شيء
رحلتك انت ها المستوى الشخصي وبعدين ادخل
على همم
عملك في السفاره وبعدين تدخل على بشكل عام
السعوديه والعالم اليوم همم كحراك
دبلوماسي خلينا نبدا اول شيء نعرف ايش
اللي يخليك في 2007 تختارين وزاره
الخارجيه للعمل خريجه تحاسب اهلي اه في
الوقت اللي 2007 فرص المراه في اغلب المهن
ضعيفه
يعني يعني يسود فيها الرجال بشكل واضح
طبعا لما تقول همم وزاره خارجيه
ودبلوماسيه اكيد انه صراحه جدا جاذب
الموضوع عمل دبلوماسي عمل سياسي انك ان
تعمل فيه وزراء عدد السيدات كان في سيدات
في وزاره الخارجيه لما الان انظمه العمل
فيها لكن محدود جدا بالنسبه لي كانت يعني
فرصه عظيمه ويعني قدمت على المسابقه هذه
القطاع هل في احد من الاسره في هالمجان
بس بالنسبه لي كان عالم غريب
والله والله احب العمل السياسي وعندي شغف
الى اخره اذا كان عالم غير مكتشف كنت احس
انه هذه فعلا ممكن تكون تجربه مختلفه
تماما
الفرص الوظيفيه التقليديه اللي كانت
المراه في ذلك الوقت وفعلا يعني الحمد لله
الحمد لله يعني الحمد لله انه انا وفقت في
القبول بوسات الخارجيه والحمد لله انه انا
تاخرت هذا المساء لانه صراحه عمل جدا ممت
غني عمل همم يعني متغير بشكل مستمر وعمل
يجبرك على انك تتطور بشكل متسارع جدا
لتواكب همم
التغييرات الكبيره جدا اللي قاعده العالم
بشكل كبير في كل المجالات بما في ذلك
العمل الدبلوماسي او تدرجتي في عده مهام
داخل الوزاره قبل ما تكون السفيره لو
نستعرض بشكل سريع ايش هي المهام اللي
مريتي فيها بعد التحقي بالوزاره باقل همم
من سنه اصبحت لي الفرصه للعمل في سفاره
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والصراحه هذا شيء يعني همم يحسب على وزاره
الخارجيه انه صحيح انه فتره التمكين تعيش
المراه حاليا ما جاءت الا مع الرؤيا
ومستهدفات الرؤيه لكن في وزاره الخارجيه
لوزاره كانت صداقه
بحيث ان الفرس كانت موجوده مستعد انه يقلص
اكلت الفرص متاحه العمل في بعثات المملكه
في الخارج المتاح للمراه في الوسعه
الخارجيه من وقت الالتحاق في الوساره
وفعلا انا رحت وعملت في سفاره المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في كامبرا واستراليا
وتعلمت طبعا
الكثير من عملي في السفاره لانه في اختلاف
نوعا ما بين طبيعه العمل في السفارات
وطبيع العمل في همم ديوان الوزاره في
الرياض وكانت التجربه جدا تاريخيه خمس
سنوات تقريبا اربع سنوات
السير في العلاقات الدوليه من الجامعه
الوطنيه الاستراليه في كامره
بعدها لما رجعت لحقت بمركز الدراسات
والمعلومات والمركز
الرئيسي يعني احنا همم
ابرز الدراسات العالميه في مجال السياسي
والدبلوماسي ونعمل لها زي التحليل
والاناسه
خلال العمل المركز همم كان في مهام احيانا
من وقت الى اخر مختلفه عن طبيعه العمل في
المركز وكلف اا فيها انا وعدد من زميلاتي
وايضا زي ما قلت الوسط الخارجيه كانت
سباقه في هذا المجال بحيث انه كان فرصه
جدا متاحه انه للسيدات انهم يمثلون
المملكه في المحافل الاقليميه والدوليه
يعني مبسوطون المملكه في وفاه الوجع
لخارجيا يمثلون المملكه من خلال المشاركه
في دولات دورات تدريبيه متخصصه في الداخل
او في همم في الخارج
يه في الوزاره
للشؤون السياسيه
المشهد الوزاره عشان اللي يقدر يتخيل ايش
طبيعه الاقسام الادوار ايش علاقه السفارات
في الوزاره هل عندك مشهد مبسط الوزاره
يعني في علاقات ثنائيه مع دول وفي علاقات
متعدده الاطراف مع منظمات او على علاقات
تحكمها موضوعات محدده فالوزاره تقريبا
مقسمه بهذا الشكل عندنا مجموعه من
الوكالات وكاله الوزاره والشؤون الدوليه
المتعدده اللي بتوعنا به علاقات المملكه
مع المنظمات الدوليه والاقليميه
والاتحادات والتجمعات الى اخره وعندنا
وكاله الوزاره للشؤون السياسيه عندنا
وكاله للوزاره للشؤون الاقتصاديه الثنائيه
وكاله للوزاره للتخطيط الاستراتيجي همم
وكان الشؤون القنصليه وكاله الوزاره
للشؤون المراسم فكل المهام اللي تندرس
طبيعه العمل السياسي والدبلوماسي لها
وكاله متخصصه في وزاره الخارجيه تعنى فيها
حاليا في تقريبا سبع وكالات
السفارات تتبع اي اي وكاله فيهم السفارات
عاده تدفع لسمو الوزير مباشره
لكن بحسب طبيعه الموضوعات
السفاره يعني ترفعها لديوان الوزاره تحال
الى الوكاله المختصر
وكمنظومه وش الاجهزه او الكيانات اللي
تعتبر منظومه وزاره الخارجيه يعني معهد
الامير سعود الفيصل الله يرحمه هذا يعتبر
تابع المنظومه
او جزء منها
احد وفعلا المعهد همم يعني يركز اكثر على
تدريب الكفاءات الدبلوماسيه عندنا دوبلوم
همم
ال- اا ملحق الدبلوماسي لما الشخص يعني
ينضم للعمل في وزاره الخارجيه يتاح له
الفرصه همم انه همم يعني يدرس دبلوم عالي
في مجال الدراسات الدبلوماسيه في دورات
متخصصه ايضا يقيمها المعهد بشكل مستمر
طوال العام متاحه لموظفي وزاره الخارجيه
والقطاعات الاخرى كانت قديما حكرا على
موظفي وزاره الخارجيه لكن الان مع همم
التنوع المهام ليقوموا فيها الاشخاص في كل
الوزارات ولايات الحكوميه فاتحت الفرصه
الاستفاده من هذه الدوره
بصراحه انه الافراد ما يقدرون يقدمون بشكل
مباشر على الماء احد بس غالبا هي عن طريق
يكون عن طريق هذه
الحكوميه همم بعد ما يصير اتعمل في في
وزاره الخارجيه وبعض السفارات همم تم
اختيارك سفيره ل خادم الحرمين الشريفين في
ابريل 2021 همم ثالث سفيره امراه في في
تاريخ السعوديه والفتره اللي يعني من بعد
الرؤيه شهدت حراك
مكثف في القاده ااه السيدات في هذا القطاع
فمثلا
سبتمبر 2017 متحدث رسميا لسفاره سفاره
السعوديه واشنطن الامير ريما بنت بندر
سفيره لامريكا في فبراير 2019 همم
الدكتوره امل الفطاني وملحقا ثقافيه في
بريطانيا فوق 2020 همم دكتور يسرا
الجزائري قائمه الثقافي في المملكه
المغربيه
في النرويج همم
الاميره هيفاء
عندنا مجموعه قاده سيدات في فتره ما بعد
الرؤيه بعد 2016 همم
وانت احدهم فولدر نعرف
ايش هي معايير اختيار السفير او السفيره
وش طبيعه عملك كسفيره بالنسبه للمعايير
الاختيار احنا عندنا واحده اسمها مجلس
السلك الدبلوماسي في وزاره الخارجيه
بعضويه كبار المسؤولين في الوزاره في
اعاده من يعني تفرز الاسماء او تضع
الترشيحات بالقوائم ثم ترفع المقام همم
وهذا المجلس مكون منسوبي الوزاره
من الدبلوماسيين حسب امكانياتهم بحسب
خبراتهم اللغات اللي يعرفونها الى اخره
وبناء عليها
الوعاء هل هم موظفين السفارات ولا موظفين
الوزاره ولا ايش الوعاء الذي يتم ترشيح
السفراء منه
دبلوماسيين في وزاره الخارجيه سواء كان في
سفاره سواء كان في ديوان الوزاره سواء كان
في منظمه دوليه يعمل باسم ال- ال- الوزاره
اي شخص يلتحق بالعمل في وزاره الخارجيه في
سلم الوظائف الدبلوماسيه احنا نسميها وفي
السلم هذا الاهرام كينج بالملحق الى مرتبه
صفير
ايش في ايش في بينهم
مش طبيعه عمل السفير ترى في ناس انها
وظيفه الاحلام تقعد في بلد راتب وتحضر
مناسبه اجتماعيه ههه
انا متاكد انه اكثر من ذلك
الاعضاء على السفير حضور المناسبات
الاجتماعيه
بشكل تقريبا شبه يومي مناسبه كبيره
يحضرونها مسؤولين ويحضرونها سفراء
المعتمدين في الدوله المضيفه ولازم خلال
هذه المناسبه انت تكون في افضل حالاتك
قادر على انك تحاول الناس قادر على انك
تنقل صوره ايجابيه عن بلدك والاشل تطور
الحاصل فيها همم قادر على ان تتعرف على
شخصيات جديده تنفعك في عملك القادم وعقادر
على انك ايضا همم تناقش موضوعات تبغى
تناقشها مع مسؤولين معينه تنتهي فرصه
وجودهم في هذه المناسبه همم
مهنه السفير يعني تتطلب صراحه انه شخص
يكون له لديه ال- ال- الكثير من همم
المؤهله
والامكانيات والمهارات عشان ينجح فيها
يعني الفكره هي هو طبعا الممثل لبلده
واعلام ممثل ببلده في الدوله المضيفه لكن
في نفس الوقت انا ابغى اعرف ايش اللي صاير
في البلد المضيف اللي انا معتمد لديها
لازم انقل الصوره بشكل دقيق جدا احلل
المشهد السياسي الاقتصادي الاجتماعي اعرف
ايش تاثيرات ذلك على علاقاتي انا من كم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه مع هذا البلد
التاثير ذلك على علاقات هذه البلد مع
محيطها
ايوه لازم انه انا اكون ملم تماما بما
يحصل في بلدي من ناحيه المشهد السياسي
الدبلوماسي اقتصادي والان ثقافي سياحي
اجتماعي مع الاطلاق رؤيه المملكه 20 30 في
واصبح الان احنا كسفراء للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه جزء كبير من دورنا غير الادوار
التقليديه طبعا اللي يمارسها السياسيه بس
جزء كبير من دورنا نحن ننقل رحله التحول
الممتعه رحله التحول الغير مسبوقه في
المملكه
للدوله المضيفه ولكل الاشخاص اللي احنا
نلتقي فيهم لانه عملت
تلتقي ممثلين عن دول كثيره في زياراتهم
للدوله اللي انت فيها وهم يكونوا معتمدين
للدوله اللي انت سافر فيها همم
ايش اللي صاير من تطورات هائله وتطورات
صراحه تدعو للخر لان انا لما اقدر يعني في
اي مقابله مع اي مسؤول جزء يعني محدد يكون
عن همم المسائل التقليديه اللي دائما
اتكلم عنها علاقات ثنائيه اقتصاديه الى
اخره لكن الجزء الرئيسي يكون من المقابله
الحديث عن منجزات الرؤيه ايش اللي يتحقق
ايش اللي نطمح ان احنا نحقق ان شاء الله
في المستقبل القريب وايش الفرص اللي قاعد
تجريح الرؤيه لهذه الدول انها تنخرط بشكل
اكبر معنا
عشان ما اسمع شو ماكو خطا الى الان ما شفت
شيء غير المناسبات الاجتماعيه
ومحاضرات في مراكز الفكر والابحاث يقيم هو
السفيره والسفاره بشكل عام هي ايضا لها
دور
المملكه
خلال الفتره الراهنه انشطه للتعريف
الاحداث معينه ممكن مقاومه في المملكه او
المملكه ترقب ترغب في استضافتها همم طبعا
الجزء كبير من عملنا اجتماعات رسميا مع
الجهات الرسميه للدوله النظيفه
همم لو بندخل جوه السفاره وايش هيك
السفاره في سفير طيب ومين تحته عده في
نائب طبعا لرئيس البعثه همم
السفير رئيس البعثه
وفينا طبعا في كل سفاره لها نائب لرئيس
البعثه بعدين في عدد من الاقسام حسب حجم
السفاره طبعا الحجم السفاره يتحدث بحسب
اهميه البلد او الدوله المضيفه بحسب حجم
العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدان اجسام
سياسي اقتصادي اعلامي ممكن قسم مراسم الى
اخرهكم همم ايش الاقسام الموجوده فيها
واشهد دوار الموظفين فيها عندنا قسم سياسي
قسم اقتصادي وقسم اعلامي هذه الاقسام
الرئيسيه سياسيه
ملحق ثقافي وملحق عسكري هذول فريقكم ههه
همم
جزء من صح لكنهم مكتب تقريبا شبه منفصل
اوكي فهم ليس ضمن التسع اشخاص
في البلد المضيف تحت مظلت السفاره لكن ما
هم من ضمن لا فريق عمل السفاره نفسها في
اليوم الفريق السفاره اللي تحت قياده 9
اشخاص من ضمنهم الملحق العسكري والثقافه
عسكري او ملحق ثقافي الملحقيه الثقافيه
اللي تشرف على لو كان في طلبه مثلا
سعوديين جالسين في السويد والحقيقه
الثقافيه في برلين الماني
[موسيقى]
كيف يعني تلقيتي الخبر حق الترشيح
ومن وجهه نظرك وايش كانت اهم المعايير
يعني مثلا هل يجب ان يكون لك علاقه بهذه
الدوله او تعرفين تتحدثين لغتهم وش وش
بالظبط معايا الاختيار السفير طبعا كل ما
كان السفير ملم اكثر بالدوله او عنده
تربطوا علاقه سابقه فيها كثير تسمع عن
سفراء همم عمل في فتره من الحياه ومثلا
كسر ثالث سكر ثانيه في الدوله بعد ارجع
لها
مثلا في هذه الدوله هي اللي كانت
نقطه ايجابيه اضافيه تحسب له الامام بلغه
همم الدوله اللي انت رايح لها طبعا همم
شرط اساسي مهم جدا وانت
فيلم بلغه رسميه في الدوله بالنسبه للسويد
اللغه الانجليزيه تعد احد اللغات الرسميه
والسويديين بشكل عام يتحدثون الانجليزيه
بطلاقه
السويديه هي اللغه ما يتحدثها الا العشره
مليون سويدي المقيمين في السويد
اللغه الانجليزيه
[موسيقى]
افضليه يشوف احنا احيانا السفارات كده همم
ادائهم همم غير اعتيادي يعني مثلا في
السعوديه
في تويتر مثلا اشوف السفير الياباني اشوف
السفير الفرنسي همم
يحضرون فعاليات المجتمع يتكلمون باللغه
العربيه نسمعهم كده وان كانت مثلا
بطلاقه لكن انهم تعلموا هذه اللغه قريبا
في خاطبونا بلغتنا يحضرون مناسباتنا دائما
السفيل ياباني يقول اضرب بالخمسه او يعني
قاعد اتعشى كبسه كده هذا النوع من الادوار
هل هي
مبالغه ممكن تؤدي الى اخطاء ولا مخاطر ولا
هي مطلوبه من السفير
اللي انت همم عايش فيه وانت كسفير تكون
ملم
بثقافات هذا المجتمع باهم مناسبات وتشارك
فيها اكيد لها يعني هيقول لك الافضليه
والنقطه تحسب لك همم لكن زي يمكن مع حضرتك
تفضل انه الخطا فيها
بيصير ولد اكثر اذا الواحد دخل فيه تفاصيل
التفاصيل همم وبحسب طبيعه المجتمع اللي
انت فيه مدى تقبلهم والله انك خطا في احد
تقاليدهم وهمم واحد مناسباتهم يختلف من
المجتمع الى اخر لكن بشكل عام اي مجتمع
انت يمكن تشوفوا تقبل المج السعودي للسفير
الياباني او الفرنسي او يعتبر لانه همم
فعلا قاعدين يشاركون في مناسباتنا
ويتحدثون لغتنا ويتكلمون عن همم تقاليدنا
الى اخره ففي تقبل من المجتمع لهذا الامر
في متابعه لهم وهذا الشيء طبعا يحسب لهم
لانه الان صار عنده منصه كبيره يتكلم من
خلالها يرسل من خلالها الرسائل اللي هو
يبغى يرسلها عن بلده عن علاقاتها مع
المملكه
في نشاطك في السويد اخذتي الخط الرسمي
البعيد عن المجتمع ولا انخراطم على
المجتمع
الحدود نفسه
العامه والدبلوماسيه العامه كيف احنا نؤثر
على الراي العام
البلدان الاخرى وهذه اصبحت احد الادوات
التي تستخدمها وزاره الخارجيه يعني من
عقود مو من الان اييي كيف انه نحن ناثر في
الراي العام وعلى شان اثر على الراي العام
لازم انا اكون فاعل في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بحسب طبعا الموقع الاكثر
استخداما في البلد المضيف لازم انا اكون
حاضر اعلاميا ولازم انا اكون عندي القدره
انه انا انقل الرسائل اللي انا ابغى
انقلها عن بلدي
يعني عبر القناه المناسبه في البلد المضيف
يعني تعودنا
بان مرحله الرؤيه هي مرحله مستدفات
ومؤشرات واضحه لكل الجهات او اغلب الجهات
وهذا نعتمد عليه السقفات في متابعه اداء
الجهات المختلفه
فهلنا طبعا هو مش معلن بس هل هو داخليا
عندكم انتم مستندات عندكم
سفيره كيف ايز معينه تابعها الوزاره
اجتماعات هيك مشاركتك في مراكز الفكر
والابحاث همم لقاءاتك الاستضافات اللي
يستضيف على السفير المناسبات اللي يقيمها
الى اخر همم ايش هي الخطوط الحمراء على
السفير اللي هي لو كان لو ما كان سفير
مقبوله منه بس كسفير انه ما يتجنب هذه
تماما همم
شيء وهذا معروف في السياسيه والدبلوماسي
عدم تدخل في شؤون
الدوله المظيفه
يتجاوزونه
ياخذهم الحماس سوء تقدير الموقف الى اخره
فعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
هي تعزيز العلاقه الثنائيه بين بلد
والدوله اللي هو رايح لها عشان يعني
يستطيع القيام بهذه المهمه على اكمل وجه
جزء رئيس مهم ان هو ما يتدخل بشكل مباشر
في الشونه الداخليه البلد ال- همم اللي
رايح له همم اليوم السعوديه عندها مشروع
همم واضح ومهم جدا في جانب همم تنشيط
السياحه واستقرار السياحه
جانب الاستثمارات الاجنبيه همم الى البلد
هل يمارس السفير والسفاره دور في هالجربه
همم
الرئيسيه لكن احنا جهه مساعده او مسانده
في همم سواء جد بالاستثمارات او الترويج
للسياحه همم حسب همم يعني خطط الجهات همم
المعنيه لكن في العمليه شيء انتم مارستوه
او لسه ما في شيء ما في امثله محدده لكن
بشكل عام معروف في استراتيجيات معينه لكل
اتجاه كل دوله وايش همم الفرص اللي احنا
نرغب في تعزيزها مع هذه الدوله وكيف نبغى
نعزز هذه الفرص هذه ترسل لكم طبعا طبعا
طيب اذا هي لكم ليش ما صار شيء يعني على
هذا السياق من ناحيه استثمارات اجنبيه
ما في ارقام معينه لحد الان همم لكن بشكل
عام في تزايد همم
اعداد السياحي
ماشي سواد همم دور غير مباشر يعني ما هي
ادوار مباشره الادوار الغير مباشره انه
احنا جزء من عملناه واحنا نعرف انه والله
الان اصبحت السياحه في المملكه احد عوامل
الجذب بالنسبه للمملكه عندنا تاشيره
الكترونيه يعني هذا اكثر شيء يصاب فيه ال-
ال- السائح السعودي بالصراحه دخول انه انا
عندي تاشيره الكترونيه انت تقدر تقدم على
التاشيره
الالكترونيه وممكن تصل لك خلال ساعه انا
قبلت اشخاص لمن همم اقابل شخص يقول لي انا
صوره المملكه طبعا احب اسال متى كيف كان
انطباعك واذا كان بعد اطلاق التاشيره
الالكترونيه اسال كم استغرق اطلاق
التاشيره الالكترونيه اقدر اقول بكل فخر
انه كثير يعني همم ردود على سؤالي انه اقل
من ساعه اقل من ساعه اقل من ساعه صدرك
وتاشيره الالكترونيه بالنسبه للاشخاص اللي
انه سبق له زياره المملكه قبل الاطلاق
التاشيره الالكترونيه والتاشيره السياحيه
بتجري ثاني يقارن سواء من ناحيه التكلفه
من ناحيه المتطلبات المستندات المطلوبه او
من ناحيه الوقت المستغرق لاصدار التاشيره
احنا بنتكلم مثلا عن تاشيره العمره كانت
تقريبا في المتوسط داخل 14 يوم الان نقدر
نقول بكل ثقه في خمس دقائق تصل لك تاشيره
العمره اذا استكملت البيانات بشكل صحيح
ممكن خلال 5 دقائق
تاشيره عمره همم الناس اللي ما عندها
معلومات محدثه ايش اللي حصل عن فتح مثلا
باب العمره لجميع همم الضيوف من المسلمين
من كل دول العالم همم كيف انه توسعنا في
الارقام وكيف عندنا مستهدفه ان شاء الله
في 2030 انه زائرين المشاعر المقدسه نوصل
الى 30 مليون همم زائر همم كل هذه احنا
لنا دور رئيسي كثافه احنا احنا نروج لهذه
المعلومات ونشرها بافضل همم طريقه ممكنه
ونجيب على الاستفسارات طبعا اللي تيجي هنا
في هذا الشان
يعني كمتابعه عامه دايما نسمع
استدعاء السفير للتشاور سحب السفير ااا
طرد السفير دايما السفير هو اوضح حلقه في
العلاقات بين اييي الدول فودنا يعني
نفهم اكثر ايش ايش معنى كل مصطلح من هذه
ايش تبيعاته
همم في حال وجود توتر في العلاقات بين
بلدين في مجموعه من الاجراءات ممكن للدوله
انها تكون فيها للتعبير عن التعاض عامل
موقف الدوله الاخرى تجاه قضيه معينه الى
اخره تبدا من ممكن همم
استدعاء السفير لدوله
هذه تترك المجال لعوده همم بدون اي همم
ممكن تغير كبير في المواقف الى اخره
وتترك المجال ايضا الوقت هو راجع للتشاور
قد استغرق هذا التشاور ايام اشهر الى اخره
همم ممكن صح كامل
للسفير لمده ايضا غير محدده احيانا بعض
الدول تسحب السفير او السفير للتشاور بدون
ما تعلن عن
الموضوع الهدف طبعا الاحتواء ال ال يمكن
سوء تفاهم الحاصل ومحاوله معالجه المساله
بشكل ثنائي عبر القنوات الدبلوماسيه
واحيانا الهدف طبعا واضح ومحددا انه دوله
تبغى تصاعد اكثر فتعلن عن عمليه سحب
السفير رئيس الاسباب اللي بناءا عليه
الدوله
السفير الفلاني لم يعد نرحب به في المكان
الفلاني او في الدوله واللي هي ينتج عنها
ان هو يغادر احيانا البعثه كلها تغادر على
حسب التصعيد همم يعني ايش فرقها عن
استدعاء السفير
الدوله
العلاقات
تحدد شخص او مجموعه اشخاص الدبلوماسيه
لديها بما في ذلك السفير لانه اشخاص غير
مرغوب فيها وعاده عنده 48 ساعه لمغادرات
الدوله المضيفه ومن حقها ايضا انها تسوي
هذا الاجراء بدون ذكر الاسباب
فيحدث كثيرا انه دبلوماسيين وليس سفراء
وتجي احيانا في حاله امثله على سفراء لكن
دبلوماسيين يمكن تسمعون عنها كثير يعلن
عنها ان والله الدوله قررت انه دبلوماسي
اثنين ثلاثه شخص واحد من سفاره معينه همم
اصبحوا اشخاص غير مرغوب بهم اما لانه
الدوله مثلا تشك انه هم همم
يقوموا بممارسه فيها تدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه للدوله المضيفه يقومون باعمال
همم الدوله ترى انها اعمال تجسس الى اخره
في حددوا هذا الاشخاص على انهم اشخاص غير
مرغوب فيها همم احيانا بعض الدول ترجع الى
اسلوب المعامله بالمثل وهي ايضا فعل انه
مثلا شخص او شخصين بحسب كم عدد العدد اللي
اعلنت الدوله الاولى الاولى اشخاص غير همم
مرحبا همم
يعني همم عمل كسفيره الى البلد المستضيفه
همم السويد لان هذه شكلها يعني يعني
على فكره في واحده خضراء واسمها ايسلند
وحده همم شهب او اسمها
ملخبط حقهم احد الروايات انه مستكشف
ايسلنت همم لما همم يعني همم ابحر الى
ايسلند وعايش فيها فتره الصيف وجاء الثلج
تجمدت محاصيل والماشيه اللي عنده الى اخر
وما يقدر انه يعني يعيش هناك فقرر انه
يرحل ينزح عنها وقال انها بلد بارده جدا
وغير قابله للعيش وسميت»
استن همم فلوس درجات حراره منخفضه جدا
عرفيني عن السويد وعن ايسلندا اهم الاهم
المعلومات اللي يمكن المتابعه والمستمع
يكون معتم يعرفها بالنسبه للسويد همم
وايسلندا كلهم دول اسكندنافيه ولمن همم
يمكن تكلمنا فيها قبل بدايه التسجيل
للحوار لما نتكلم عن دول الاسكندنافيه
فاحنا نتكلم عن دول همم بمعدلات عاليه جدا
همم او تتصدر دول العالم في همم الرفاه
الاجتماعي في جوده الحياه ان تتميز السويد
يمكن عن غيرها من الدول الاسكندنافيه في
انها الدوله رقم واحد عالميا في معدل
الابتكار
هذا الشيء ناتج عن التعاون الوثيق ما بين
الحكومه في سنه تشريعات
تنمي الابتكار وتعززه وما بين الجامعات
وما بين القطاع الخاص بحيث انه دائما لما
يكون في فكره او ابتكار معين سهل جدا على
الشخص المبتكر انه يعني يتواصل بشكل مباشر
مع القطاع الخاص يحول فكرته الى واقع
وبعدين ممكن بحث القدره على تسويق هذه
الفكره همم
في الدوله نفسها او اقليميه لو حتى عالميه
عشره مليون عشره مليون فقط
المجتمع السويدي
مجتمع السويدي مجتمع محافظ
ومتحفظين
لكنهم
على العادات والمعتقدات
والمعتقدات لازال عندهم اكثر من غيرهم من
الدول الاوروبيه مفهوم الاسره والترابط
الاسري الى اخره الى حد ما طبعا يختلف من
المدينه المدينه من منطقه الى منطقه لكن
بشكل عام يعني افضل من غيرهم من الدول
المتحفظ في علاقاته بسبب طبيعه همم يمكن
الحياه عندهم وطبيعه العلاقات الاجتماعيه
همم في همم يعني همم
العلاقات الاجتماعيه عندهم لها حدود
واقامه العلاقات الاجتماعيه ما ياتي
بثلاثه يعني ممكن انت تتعرف على شخص
وتتبادلون الحديث حول موضوعات محدده الى
اخره لكن هذا لا يعني ابدا انك انت في
نهايه اللقاء ممكن تطلب تبادل ارقام
[موسيقى]
اذا كان الواحد يعني حاول يتعلم
عن عادات وتقاليد
البلد
وكيف ممكن ينخرط فيها بافضل شكل ممكن
هيساعده في فهم يعني هذه الامور في
مبالغات يعني انا قبل ما اروح همم
شخص اسكندنا العافيه انه لو حاولتي 20 كده
السلام على احد جيرانك وما رد لا تاخذي
منها بشكل شخصيه هم طبيعتهم
[موسيقى]
ممارسه يمكن في بعض المبالغه لطيفين
لطيفين جدا جدا على انهم يتعلمون عن الاخر
ما يعرفون الكثير يمكن بسبب البعد
الجغرافي عدم وجود عوامل مشتركه كثيره
لكنهم منفتحينهم يتعلمون ايش صاير في في
يعني بلدان العالم بشكل عام بما في ذلك
طبعا اكيد المملكه امم يعني
الصوره الذهنيه والمقالات وحتى البرامج
التلفزيونيه دائما كان العالم العربي يجلد
بالمقارنه يا جماعه الدول الاسكندنافيه
وان هذول هم ارهب ناس واحسن ناس وكل شيء
عندهم تمام وشوف الحياه عندهم كيف تعامل
مع الحيوانات مع الانسان يعني كانت هي لا
لاند او ال- ال- المدينه الفاضله اذا صحت
التسميه الى اي مدى هذا الكلام دقيق
كل مجتمعها اكيد عنده نواحي قصور وعنده
مشاكل يحتاج ان هو يعالجها اييي احد يمكن
المشكلات اللي ظهرت في السنوات الاخيره في
السويد ارتفاع معدلات الجريمه يعني يمكن
الواحد لما يعرف انه والله السويد دوله
اسكندرافيه ونتكلم عن زوجته حياه الى اخره
وامان وتقدم وتطور لكن هي رقم واحد ما بين
الدول الاوروبيه في حوادث اطلاق النار
فكل المجتمع يعني عنده اكيد قضايا محدده
يحتاج ان هو همم يعني يعمل يمكن عليها
ويعالجها ويعالج التحديات المرتبطه فيها
[موسيقى]
دائما لما يعني يتم الحديث عن السلامه
المروريه يضرب المثال بالسويد
ومستهدف صفر حوادث
ما عندي والله تفاصيل محدده عن المستهدف
سفر حوادث بس فعلا الحوادث تكون تكاد لا
تذكر في السويد
حوادث مروريه عالي جدا وضعوا خطه للوصول
الى الصفر حادث مروري او وفيات حوادث
واظن انهم كانوا قريبين جدا منا او حققوه
مؤخرا دائما استشهد في السلامه المروريه
بحكمنا بلد مره متاخر في هذا المستهدف في
الحمد لله
في نقطه يعني مؤلمه في هذا الجانب همم
يعني بما نتكلم على على السويد في سياسين
سويدين
ذكروا انه ال ال الاسلام دين بغيض
والمسلمين اكبر تهديد للسويد
هل هذه الصوره اللي موجوده عن المسلمين في
السويد
تقريبا
[موسيقى]
منهم من المسلمين اللغه العربيه هي
الثانيه لغه تحدثتا في السويد بعد السويد
مامور استخدام اللغه كاستخدام للغه لكن
اشخاص ولغتهم الرسميه او لغتهم الاساسيه
هي اللغه العربيه فلمن تقارن الاشخاص
لغتهم الاساسيه السويديه بعد ذلك ياتي عدد
الاشخاص اللي لغتهم الاساسيه اللغه
العربيه في المرتبه الثانيه بعد اللغه
السويديه في عدد المسلمين
كبير جدا في السويد في العديد من الجمعيات
الاسلاميه مراكز اسلاميه مساج الى اخره في
الانتخابات اللي جرت في السويد في سبتمبر
20 همم 22 الماضي همم وصل الى السلطه
تحالف من الاحزاب اليمين همم الحزب
الرئيسي فيها كان حزب المحافظين
ووصل الى السلطه لاول مره في تاريخ السويد
حزب يميني متطرف همم اسمه حزب الديمقراطيو
السؤال فغالبا اغلب ال- ال-
الاتهامات او الشعارات او الانتقادات تاتي
من الاحزاب
اليمينيه المتطرفه
اسهل ولا اكثر تحديا التعاون مع حكومه لها
هذه النظره تجاه
المنطقه تجاه الاسلام تجاه السعوديه
الحكومه بشكل عام احنا ما نقدر
نعملها هذه النظره تجاه الاسلام
المحافظين حسب المسيح الديمقراطي وحزبراني
وحزب الديمقراطيه والسويد اليمين المتطرف
فالاحزاب الاربعه هذه تحالفت لتشكيل
الحكومه عاده السياسات التي تضعها الحكومه
او توجهاتها في سياساتها الخارجيه لازم
تكون بتوافق
هذه الاحزاب الاربعه ف يعني ما نقدر نقول
والله انه تكون في حزب يميني متطرف في
الحكومه هذا يعني انه سياسات الحكومه بشكل
عام هتكون متطرفه في جاهل الاسلام وبشكل
العام طبعا علاقات المملكه مع السؤال
علاقات متميزه جدا السوء تعتبر المملكه
شركه تجاري الاكبر للسواد في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وبالنسبه لنا احنا اسود الشركه
التجاري الاكبر لنا من بين الدول
الاسكندنافيه واكثر دوله يعني
نستورد منها همم من بين الدول
الاسكندرافيه وفي فرص كبيره جدا لتعزيز
العلاقات بين البلدين في كافه
المجلات ومع الفرص الكبيره اللي قاعده
تتيح رؤيه المملكه 20 همم 30 وسعيد دول
الاقتراس هذه
في المجالات طبعا فيها وفي المجالات التي
تحتاجها في المملكه همم
المساحه همم يعني موجوده ان شاء الله
اذا العلاقات بشكل اكبر مما هي عليه الان
وفي رغبه من الجانب يعني تعزيز العلاقات
في في 6 مارس 2015 ااا تحدثت وزيره
الخارجيه السويديه على القضاء السعودي
بشكل سلبي همم
ثالث جلسه من جلسات البرلمان على ما اعتقد
واعتبر تدخل في الشان السعودي الداخلي
وقدح في استقلال ونزاهه القضاء السعودي
على اثرها استدعت السعوديه السفير
واتفاقمت الازمه ووقفت ظنت تاشيرات العمل
وبعض العقود التجاريه همم
وكافه تصعيد عاليه من السعوديه فتدخل اظن
الملك السويدي وارسل المبعوث وكانه واحتوى
الازمه وعادت العلاقات
بشكل يعني جيد يعني انا صراحه انا ودي
افهم همم ايش مصلحه وزيره الخارجيه في شيء
من من مثل هذا النوع همم
كيف تتعاملون انتم في سفارات المملكه في
انحاء العالم ااه مع هذه النظره ال ال ال
المستمره من التدخل في الشان السعودي
الداخلي
وممارسه الوصايه او ممارسه التنظير
والاستاذيه على على السعوديه في كثير من
الملفات الملفات تغير والنظره والاسلوب
مستمر وش اللي يدفعهم لمثل هذا التدخل
دورنا احنا كتبنا وماسيين انه احنا نعزز
فرص التعاون
ونحاول انه احنا همم يعني همم انه يعالج
همم
سوء الفهم يعالج نقاط الخلاف عن طريق
الحوار البنا
مهما كان الموضوع الخلاف ممكن معالجته
والحديث عنه عن طريق الحوار البناء طبعا
المملكه ترفض باي شكل كانت تدخل في شؤون
الهداخليه وهذا امر غير مقبول تماما
مثل هذه الامور فرد احيانا في العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بشكل مختلف الدول العالم ويتم
معالجتها بالطرق المناسبه
انا بتكلم بشكل عام ابغى احاول افهم لان
انتم احتكتو فيهم انتم جلستوا معهم سمعتوا
منهم ما الذي يدفع
المجتمع الغربي للاعتقاد بانه هي التي يجب
ان تسود في العالم ويجب ان يفردها على على
الشرق والغرب وعلى افريقيا واسيا وكل مكان
همم بدلا من التعايش مع همم قيم الدول
الاخرى واحترامها وايش المنطلق اللي هم
ينطلق منه لما يمارسون هذا الوصايه
بعض الدول تعتقد انها وصلت الى مرحله من
التطور
مرحله من 800 المبادئ ال ال ال الاساسيه
سواء في الحياه الاجتماعيه او السياسيه او
الى اخره
ترغب من خلالها في مشاركه النجاح لحققته
من وجهه طبعا نظرها مع الاخرين فيمكن هذا
الشيء يخليها يعني تاتي بالمنطلق انه انا
هذه تجربتي الناجحه وتعتقد انه يمكن لو
عممتها او لو حاولت نقلها الى الدول
الاخرى حتى تكلنا ايضا هذه التجربه
بالنجاح كل دوله لها خصوصياتها وكل دوله
لها ارفعها ولها تاريخها ولها خالدها ولها
عوامل وعناصر النجاح الخاصه بها واثبت
التاريخ انه حاول التعميم تجارب همم دول
اخرى او اسقاطها على همم يعني نجاح دوله
ما يسقط على دوله اخرى لن يكلل بالنجاح
احنا طبعا ناخذ
التجارب لنرى انه ممكن فيها فائده لانها
تطور في مجالات علميه معينه اليه عمل همم
الدوله في مجال ما والله نجحت فيها زي ما
حضرت مثلا والله سياسه صفر حوادث وكيف
وصلت الى هذه النتيجه او حققت ارقام عاليه
فيها فاحنا ناخذ ما يناسبنا من تجارب
وبما يتناسب طبعا مع احتياجاتنا بما
يتناسب مع عوامل القوه اللي عندنا وبناء
عليه نستفيد من الخبرات
الجيده عن طريق تبادل الخبرات ونقل
الخبرات يمكن هذا عنصر اساسي تركز عليها
المملكه في السنوات الرؤيا كيف انا ابني
الامكانيات وامكانيات المواطن السعوديه
بشكل عام وكيف انا انقل الخبرات اللي
قاعدتها عن طريق عمل الشركات الاجنبيه
المختلفه في المملكه
الاجنبي المختلفه في المملكه في المشاريع
المختلفه والمجالات المختلفه
واستغلها الوقت وانت تتقهوين عشان اقول لك
على
اقتباس من كلام الامير محمد بن سلمان في
واحده من لقاءات ولما كان يقول همم عن
يعني احيانا التدخل المبالغ فيه من امريكا
في فرض قيامها وافكارها على بعض المجتمعات
من ضمن المجتمع السعودي وكان يضرب مثال
همم مرحله تحرير العبيد وكان الامير محمد
يقول بانه قوه امريكا هي في ان تقدم نفسها
نموذج همم
فالعالم يتبع الشيء الجيد في هذا النموذج
وما يناسبه واللي ما يناسبه مو بالضروره
انه انه ياخذه وضرب مثال على موضوع تحليل
العبيد تحليل العبيد السعوديه في عهد
الملك فيصل اخذت هذه الخطوه همم الانسانيه
المهمه بدون فرض من امريكا وبدون قطع
للعلاقات وبدون ربط العقود العسكريه بهذا
القرار وانما لانه فعلا همم قدم النموذج
بشكل همم مقنع للانسانيه يتناسب مع قيمنا
الاسلاميه اللي اصلا هي دائما تشجع على
تحرير العبيد فكان كثير من ال- ال-
الافعال في الاسلام مربوطه بعتق الرقبه
همم بس التاثير جاء لان قدمت نفسك نموذج
جيد وليس لانك جاي تفرض بالغصب همم
[موسيقى]
يعني هذا الصراع الحضاري لو السعر المشهد
همم يعني في ناس متشائمين ويعتقدون انه
الامور ما هي قاعده تمشي لمسار اكثر
تعايشد
العولمه ومع تقدم المعرفي للانسان الامور
قاعده تتجه
لمسار سلبي فانتم شو رايك هل احنا اليوم
كوكب اكثر تعايشا ولا الموضوع قاعدين نرجع
وراء شوي
ان شاء الله اننا اكثر
بسبب الانفتاح زي ما حضرتك تفضلت الان
اصبحنا مفاتيحين همم اي شخص في هذا العالم
اصبح مرتبط على الاشخاص في مختلف انحاء
العالم هذا الانفتاح يمكن همم يسمح لنا
بنوع من التعاطف حيث ما احنا نبي نوع من
التفهم لما يحدث في الدول الاخرى حسب احنا
بنوع من الفهم ايضا ليسيه ساعات هذه الدول
وثقافاتها واسلوب عيشها الى اخره المملكه
العربيه السعوديه طبعا من الدول التي
تتمناه مفهوم التعايش والحوار والاساطيه
والاعتدال ونشره همم
سواء اقليميه او عالميا عن طريق همم يعني
المراكز اللي مثلا زي المركز الملك عبد
الله همم للحوار بين اتباع الاديان
والحضارات وعن طريق انشطه همم
حبيبه المنظمات الدوليه بشكل عام تعبر
وزاره الخارجيه او الهيئات في الوزارات
الحكوميه الاخرى فمفهوم التعايش احنا يعني
ممم بغض النظر لو كان نرى صوره قاتمه يمكن
للوضع حاليا همم الاعلام احيانا يحاول
يصورنا هذه الصوره وقد تكون مو هذه الصوره
الكامله همم للحقيقه لكن بشكل عام لازم
نكون صراحه متفائلين وهمم نسعى جاهدين همم
لنشر قيم التعايش والتسامح همم حول العالم
مش اكثر الملفات اللي تثار
من قبل السويديين لما يجلسون معك سواء نخب
او كم عموم المجتمع
السويد مهتمه جدا بقضايا تمكين المراه
وتبنت من عام 2014 مفهوم في السياسه
الخارجيه اسمه السياسه الخارجيه نسويه
بحيث انها تربط في الكثير من الموضوعات في
علاقاتها الثنائيه او متعدده الاطراف مع
المنظمات ما بين
تمكين المراه وتلك القضايا يعني تدفع يعني
بهذا الاتجاه بشكل او باخر همم طبعا في
تطور كبير جدا في السويد في مجال المساواه
بين ال همم الجنس يعني يعني على راس
القائمه يمكن من تاب 3 لما نتكلم عن
المسابقه بين الجنسين المركز الاول همم
تتمنى هذا المفهوم في سياستها الخارجيه
فهم حريصين جدا على انهم يفهمون ايش اللي
حاصل عندنا
وتفاجئون كثيرا في معرفه
مدى التقدم المحرس في ملف تمكين المراه
السعوديه خلال سنوات قصيره طبعا
فخورين جدا بالانجازات اللي تحققت في فتره
وجيزه جدا نادرا ما ترى دوله ممكن انها
تطور في مجال الماء زي مجال مثلا تمكين
المراه في هذه الفتره الوجيسه فهذا يعطيني
طبعا انا مجال ويعطيناك اصلا كفرات بشكل
عام يعني حول العالم مجال ان احنا نتكلم
عن همم ما تحقق من منجزات وعلى المستهدفات
في هذا الملف وايش اللي نرغب في تحقيق وان
شاء الله في المستقبل القريب واننا
نشاركنا ما عادتش همم
قياديات سعوديه همم نفخر فيهم قدوه لنا
بشكل عام الاميره ريما بنت بندر احنا
بالنسبه لنا كتب رومانسيه يعني ما اشك انه
سعوديه تنظر الى الاميره لما بن بندر كان
قدوه اساسيه لنا في مجال الدبلوماسيه بشكل
عام همم
اسماء اشرحها كبيره ما ابغى اذكر احد يعني
وعشان ما انسى احد بس
المسيره بدات همم من فتره يمكن ابرز همم
اسم همم بدا من 2001 تقريبا دكتوره عبيد
امين عام مساعد همم الامين العام للامم
المتحده فاسماء كبيره انجازات كبيره
والانجازات ان شاء الله القادمه باذن الله
هتكون همم اكبر ولما تسالين على الوضع
المراه في السعوديه كيف تنقل اللي هو
المشهد وايش اللي بيتغير
تغيرت امور كثيره جدا جدا بدايه من همم
المراجعه اللي تمت همم
احكام القضائيه نظام الاحوال الشخصيه في
ما يتعلق ببعض الجوانب اللي كانت ممكن ااا
تضع حدود على المراه من ناحيه العمل
التنقل الى اخره فكل هذه المسائل احنا لما
نتكلم عن اصلاح انه الدوله قامت في
اصلاحات همم في الانظمه لتواكب طبعا بدانا
عشان تبدا في ايه عملت صح هتبدا في مراجعه
همم الانظمه والاجراءات والى اخره وبعد ما
تراجع الانظمه الاجراءات لازم تشوف عمليه
التطبيق وايش التحديات وكيف ممكن ان احنا
نعالجها والممكنات ايضا احلى المراه
السعوديه في وقتنا الراحه وهل في
مثال او او حدث معين دايما لما تستخدمينه
تبهرينهم اييي عن عن المراه السعوديه ولا
الي صاير في المراه بحكوا ان هذا ملف يشغل
بالهم يمكن من اكثر الارقام اللي تبهر لما
نتحدث عن زياده عدد السيدات في سوق العمل
في فتره وجيزه احنا نتكلم عن 17% في 2016
ووصلنا الى تقريبا 35% في 20 22 فزياده
الكبيره هذه تقريبا يعني حوالي ضعف همم في
فتره وجيزه ولما نتكلم انه انا عندي
مستهدف كان 30% في 20 30 وحققت هذا
المستهدف قبلها وقت كبير جدا والان عندي
الامكانيه ان شاء الله اضع مسدسات طموحه
اكبر بشكل اكبر همم من المستهدف اللي كان
همم موجود هذا بحداته لانه ال- ال- العمل
جدا كبير لما لما نتكلم عن انه انا والله
ازيد اعداد السيدات في سوق العمل همم لو
التشريعات اللي الدوله لازم تضعها في هذا
المجال الممكنات اللي تضعها سواء في
القطاع الحكومي او القطاع الخاص الاليات
اللي لازم تسن همم كلها هذه في الاخير
اتت بهذه الارقام لكن بدون وجود هذا الجهد
همم بتكاتف طبعا كافه
القطاعات ما كنا وصلنا الى هذه الارقام
فيصل ودي اختم ب- همم
سؤال على حياه
السفير او السفيره الاجتماعيه واللي هي
عاده تتسم بالغربه والتنقل بين مدن دول
همم فهل يدفع الابناء ثمان طموحات اهاليهم
الدبلوماسيين
احيانا ممكن الابناء يدفعون ثمن طموحات
اهاليهم الدبلوماسيين بحسب محطات
اهاليهم واحيانا بالعكس يعني هذه تكون
يعني مفيده جدا للابناء للحصول على يعني
تعليم بجوده عاليه جدا الانفتاح على
الثقافات همم
دول اخرى
تكوين شبكه علاقات مختلفه عن اللي ممكن
يكونها لو كان والله مقيم بشكل دائم في
المملكه الى
اخرهم اسرتكم معك حاليا جزء من اسرتي معي
مدرسه همم في السويد همم لكن عندي ولدي
فيصل كان ثالث ثانوي اختار انه يكمل ثالث
ثانوي في الرياض همم بنتي راسي كانت اخر
السنه جامعه
ايضا طبعا
هنا في جامعه الملك سعود فاحيانا مو دائما
الظروف تكون مو عاتيه انه الاسره كامله
تلتحق همم مع الدبلوماسي في البلد اللي هو
رايح لها
وبحسب ايضا حتى البلد اللي هو رايح لهذا
كانت مناسبه للعائله او لا كيف همم
يعني كيف
من وجهه نظرك افضل اا السلوب الاداره
الاسره المتباعده همم بمثل الاسر
الدبلوماسيين زي زي المحل اللي عندك الحمد
لله التواصل سهل جدا في وقتنا المعاصر
يمكننا الواحد لو همم يعني يسترجعي يشوف
الناس قبل مثلا 20 سنه وما كان يعني قنوات
التواصل همم يعني كانت محدوده جدا لكن عن
التواصل الحمد لله
جمعه الخميس
عندنا جامعه الخميس
اخرها ب 9€ ههه
دائم يعني مع الاسره بشكل همم بشكل عام
والحمد لله الزيارات ايضا همم يعني تتم
بشكل دائم على هذا السياق
الرشيد كتبت اعتقد في 20 20
همم بقاله
بعنوان
سعاده الدبلوماسي المسكين كتبت هذا
المقاله في يناير 20 20 و كانت تتكلم على
مجموعه من التحديات اللي واجهتها
الدبلوماسي فكانت تتكلم على
موضوع
خطوره بعض الدول امنيه وصحيه بالذات اللي
في القاره الافريقيه
يعني يجبرهم على انهم يعيشون في دول اخرى
او انهم في بلدهم
وليكنون المرافقين لاهاليهم
ويعرضون احيانا لبعض الامراض اللي تنتشر
في بعض الدول مثل النقطه الثانيه على
موضوع السكن انه همم
الدبلوماسي يمكن ياخذ بدل السكن فيتنقل في
الدول اللي هو عايش فيها بس لما يرجع
لبلده ما يكون عنده المسكن ولا عنده المده
الكافيه لتملك هذا لانه وقت التقاعد فما
له اذا سكن وزاره الخارجيه واللي هو ما هو
تملك هو الدفاع صح في موضوع تحدث السكن
وموضوع تحدي المدارس خارج البلد المنشا
همم او بلد الاساسي همم كيف تشوفي هذا
التحدي اللي مسيره الدبلوماسي
بالنسبه للسكن والمدارس همم
اكيد هيشكل تحدي عدم الاستقرار وحاجتك
للانتقال بين فتره واخرى لكن هذا اختيار
واكيد الانسان قادر انه على انه يعني يكيف
نفسه
وبنفس الوقت قادر على انه همم يعني يوجد
الحلول اللي تناسب طبعا انت تختلف في
الحلول من شخص الى اخر زي ما حضراتك ذكرت
وزاره الخارجيه عندها همم وحدات سكنيه
بنظام الانتفاع والاولويه اعاده تكون
الاشخاص العائدين من همم يعني مهمات في
الخارج همم وفي توسع ان شاء الله في هذه
الوحدات وعددتها الى اخره بحيث انها تشمل
همم الجميع همم بالنسبه للمدارس في الدوله
المضيفه ولا همم قصدي همم
ايضا يعتمد على انت وين احيانا بالعكس
خيارات المدارس
نعم نعم نعم تغطى تكاليف
تقريبا بنسبه 100% هي لها سقف حد اعلى لكن
لحد الاعلى غالبا هذه يغطيه نسبه 100% وكل
هذا السفير كل البعثه كل البعثه كل
المزايا هذه تراها تسريب يعني كما تسريع
على السفيه وتسري على جميع اعضاء البعثه
في بعض في بعض البعثات لما زرتهم انه في
عدد من المنسوبين ما هو سعوديين همم هل في
اشتراطات من الدول الى المستضيفه لازم عدد
معين او عدم وجود سعوديين مؤهلين اوراقبين
بهذا المهل لانها بعيده ولا مش طبيعه
التوطين في وظائف السفارات والبعثات همم
البعثات الخارجيه الاساسيه كلها
سعوديين لكن في وظائف فنيه وظائف مسانده
ممكن الاستعانه يعني بحكم مثلا همم التوفر
الخبرات في البلد المضيفه الاستعانه
بامانه البلد المضيفه وهذا المطبق في همم
يعني كل السفارات الاجنبيه حول العالم همم
في اسئله غطيناها مثل دور السفاره في
استقطاب السياح هل اللغه مشترى يعني
مشترطره للسفير فدي غطيناها لكن في سؤال
هنا يقول تصنف السويد في فتره فترات
باندخل المواطنينها من اعلى مستويات الدخل
في العالم فسؤال ايش تاثير لازم اقتصاديه
العالميه على السويد وعلى المواطن العادي
اكثر طبعا همم الازمه الاقتصاديه العالميه
على السويد يمكن بشكل اقل من غيرها من
الدول في المنطقه همم لكن اكيد لها تاثير
همم جزء من نظام همم الرفاه الاجتماعي
لتمارسها الدوله انها تعطي همم يعني
الانسان سبس او تعطي همم
حوافز او مساعدات مساعدات مساعدات للافراد
للشركات همم الصغيره لتجاوز الازمات همم
الاقتصاديه لكن اكيد انه الازمه كبيره
اليوم اقرا خبر انه عدد الشركات اللي
اعلنت افلاسها في السويد هو الاكبر منذ 10
سنوات
فاكيد انها لها تاثيراتها لكن تسعى
الحكومه انها يعني تحاول تخفيف من حده هذه
التاثيرات على الاسر او على الشركات
الصغيره
في سؤال هنا وفيصل لماذا السويد بقيه
الدول الاسكندنافيه غير حاضره في المشهد
العالمي والاوروبي بتحديده
هل تمارس هذه الدول نوع من الحياد غير
معلن او موقعها الجغرافي قاعد يعزلها ليش
كده ليش السويد والسندري فيها بشكل عام ما
نشوفهم حاضرين في المشهد العالمي السؤال
بشكل
خصوصا ضمن الدول الاوروبيه همم
يناير الجاريه اسود تتراس همم
الاتحاد الاوروبي لمده سته اشهر في
الرئاسه الدوليه للاتحاد وهمم ولها نشاط
واسع في مجلات عديده خصه ما يتعلق بالطاقه
المتجدده والنظيفه وهمم تقوم بدور جدا ضمن
الاتحاد الاوروبي
يمكن ما عندها همم
الظهور والحراك اللي بنشوفها من دول ثانيه
مثلا فرنسا المانيا بريطانيا هل الحجم
الاقتصاد عدد السكان او او هي السياسه
اختياريه اكيد بشكل عام حجم الاقتصاد حجم
الدوله عدد السكان يؤثر على مدى تاثير
الدوله الاقليميه ودوليا لكن السويد مؤثره
جدا في مجال المساعدات الانسانيه تعتبر من
اكبر ال- ال- المانحين
عالميا
وتعتبر من الدول القلائل الى وقت قريب
كانت نسبه المساعدات الانسانيه فيها
تتجاوز واحد بالمئه من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي همم فلا هادور كبير وبارفرس في
هذا المجال
السعوديين للدول اسكندريه همم قليل مقارنه
بالسياح السعوديه لا اوروبا بشكل عام
السعودي يحبونه كثير بس نادر اللي يروحون
الدوله
الاوروبيه اخرى اكثر
التسويق دوله جميله جدا فيها طبيعه خلابه
متطوره جدا وفيها انشطه سياحيه كثيره يمكن
التسويق ما يخدمها لانها تعتبر
رئيسي للسياحه الاوروبيين ويمكن همم بسبب
الكرونه في الاول سنه رحنا فيها لاحظنا
هذا الشيء لكن في الصيف الماضي شفنا كيف
تحولت السكن الى مدينه سياحيه
من كل دول العالم يمكن اضيف همم سبب اخر
صحيحين وانا غلطان انا اعتقد ان هي اغلى
من متوسطه اوروبا صح ككلفه سياحيه
طيب هذا يقول ايش اهم العقود او التفاهمات
بين السعوديه والسويد اللي تدعم تحقيق
رؤيه السعوديه 2030 هل في شراكات
استراتيجيه على مستوى مشاريع الرؤيه على
مستوى البرامج رؤيا صناعات عسكريه المدن
او المشاريع الكبرى العملاقه هل في شيء
استراتيجي من السعوديه والسويد في العديد
من الشركات السعوديه
مع المملكه
لتطوير القطاع الالعاب في المملكه
الالعاب الالكترونيه اقصد سؤال قبل الاخير
ايش الاشياء اللي تتمنى لو انها في
السعوديه او انك تقدرينها من السويد الى
السعوديه اعداد اختراعات همم ثقافات اي
شيء تبغي تجيبيها معك
مدى اتباع المواطنين السويديين للانظمه
والتعليم
بضرب مثال خلال وقت الجائحه كثير من
الاجراءات اللي اتخذتها الدوله كانت عباره
عن توصيات المواطنين توصيه بلبس الكمامه
في الاماكن العامه توصيات كلها
تنفيذ هذه التوصيات هي توصيات لكن تجد انه
يعني
الاغلفه او يطبق هذه
التوصيات طالما انها توصيه هم من وجهه
نظيفه اذا انا همم افضل لمصلحتي وللمصلحه
العامه لانه انا اطبق هذه التوصيه همم
لانه اتذكر اول ما وصلنا سالنا ايش
الاجراءات او قبل حتى نسال ايش الاجراءات
المتخذه انا وصلت نهايه همم 120 و21 فكانت
الجائحه لا زالت في ذروتها فايش الاجراءات
ال- ال- ال- اللي يجب علينا اتخاذها بناء
على همم يعني الدوله المظيفه
وفوجئنا انه يعني ما كان في اي اجراء ملزم
من ضمن الاجراءات وكلها عباره عن همم
توصيات لكن همم يعني اللي تشاهدوا لما
تطلع الاماكن العامه لمن تمارس حياتك
اليوميه انه الاغلب ملتزم بهذه التوصيات
همم هذا يقول ايش اغرب موقف وجهك كسفيرا
من المواقف اللي نوعا غريبه لما يخلط
الشخص بينك وبين
سفير دوله اخرى ويقعد يتحدث معك بحماس انه
طبعا عاده دوله خليجيه انه دوله
خليجيه اخرى فيتكلم معك في حماس عنها والى
اخره وايش اللي صار وكذا وانت تبغاه بشكل
غير مباشره
يعني يمكن تقصد شيء اخر يمكن هذه من
المواقف انه
والله يمكن اقل شيء ثلاثه اربع مرات لانه
همم يعني احيانا يحدث نفس ما بين دول
الخليج انه اوكي انت يمكن
شخص متحمس يبغى يتكلم معك في موضوع معين
همم
ام فيصل على موضوع التمثيل المراه بشكل
عام وفرس السيدات البنات اللي اليوم يبغون
او يضعون انه يكون جزء همم القطاع
الدبلوماسي همم فوجه اهم ما تحقق في هذا
الموضوع طبعا الفرص المتاحه كبيره جدا
اهم ما تحقق انه تضاعف اعداد السيدات
العاملات في وزاره الخارجيه من دبلوماسيات
واداريات اليوم احنا عندنا اكثر من 150
دبلوماسيه سعوديه وعندنا اكثر من 140
اداريه تعملوا يعملون في القطاعات
الاداريه في الوزاره عندنا اكثر من 30
سيده تتقلد مناسب قياديه في وزاره
الخارجيه وفي البعثات وفي المنظمات
الدوليه
الفرص زي ما ذكرت كبيره جدا في راس
المشاركه وتمثيل المملكه في همم محافل
الاقليميه والدوليه فرص العمل في البعثات
الخارجيه والفود الرسميه للمملكه وفي
كفاءات نسائيه مميزه جدا جدا جدا في وزاره
الخارجيه وتركوا بصمتهم كلهم في مكانه
تكون سفيره وشخصياتك لها
اصبح الان يعني
حد الطموح او سقف الطموح لا محدود
يعني الحمد لله احنا نعيش فيه
وظائف معينه تزيد فرصها العمل الدبلوماسي
شامل فتندر يندرج في تخصصات كثيره يعني
دبلوماسيين من تخصصات مختلفه لكن كلها
تفيد في العمل الدبلوماسيه مهم جدا
الانسان يشتغل على نفسه يطول من ثقافته
يتعلم في التاريخ يتعلم في الادب ويتقرا
في همم
يعني ثقافات البلدان يتعلم اكيد طبعا في
همم في السياسه وفي العراق الدوليه
والعلاقات مع المنظمات همم
يحصل على تدريب ومتخصص في المهارات
الاساسيه اللي يحتاجها الدبلوماسي مثل
التواصل الفعال المفاوضات همم الدبلوماسيه
العامه وغيرها همم كل هذه ان شاء الله
هتنساهم في بناء القدرات
الدبلوماسي بشكل عام سواء سيده او رجل تس
من فرص همم ان شاء الله في يعني الحصول
على مناصب في هذه المهنه
بختم مم فيصل بسؤال عن لقاء تاريخي جمعك
برمز من رموز همم
الدبلوماسيه في السعوديه الامير سعود
الفيصل الله يرحمك
اللقاء طبعا تملي
كافر
سمو الامير سعود الفيصل الله يغفر له
ويرحمها تقريبا كان في عام 2014 طلب انه
يلتقي بجميع السيدات العاملات في الوزاره
في مكتبه وفعلا يعني طبعا بالنسبه لنا
كانت لحظه تاريخيه انه احنا نلتقي اسمه
الوزير همم
واحنا على اللقاء كل الكل طبعا
[موسيقى]
تقريبا كنا 25 لهذا الحدود
في ديوان الوزاره اللي موجوده على
الواتساب احنا اليوم نتكلم عن اكثر من 300
سيده
اجتمع معنا الله يغفر الله يرحمه في مكتبه
جدا جدا
انت مو الان
انتم في هذا الوقت انتهزوا الفصل انكم
تشتغلون على انفسكم
فانك تسمع صراحه يعني من راس الهرم في
الجهاز اللي انت فيه هذا الكلام كان دافع
كبير جدا جدا صراحه لكل انه فعلا ان شاء
الله الفرصه ستاتي
ودوري انه انا فعلا اشتغل على نفسي ولم
يقدراتي ان شاء الله الحين اا يعني تكون
هذه الفرصه ثانيه
ايضا وقتها اتذكر انه كان الهدف انه
الوزاره تهدف انه فعلا انه ال ال ال
الدبلوماسيات في في الوزاره همم يتدرجون
في سلامته الدبلوماسي للوصول الى اعلى
المناصب احنا وقت على نجتمعنا معه الله
يغفر الله يرحمك كانت سكرت ثانيه
وفعلا الحمد لله هذا الشيء تحقق الان وزي
انه في زميلات همم لي في وزاره الخارجيه
تبعون مناصب القياديه الان سواء في
الوزاره المملكه في الخارج وفخورين جدا
انا شخصيه فقط زملائي
نتطلع للنماذج الناجحه ذكرنا الاميره ريما
ساعات السفيره عمال المعلمي ااه نتعلم
منها الكثير الاميره هي في المقرن المندوب
الدائم للمملكه في همم يونسكو همم النماذج
مشرفه كثيره جدا او زي ما ذكرتنا احنا
نستفيد من تجاربهم نتعلم منهم الكثير
القيادات في وزاره الخارجيه يعني على
مختلف مستويات وهم دعمهم للمراه بشكل عام
بصراحه يعني كان همم
غير محدود لانه يمكن انا ذكرت خلال اللقاء
انه من سنوات همم يعني همم من التحاق
بالعمل في الوسالات الخارجيه انا وزميلاتك
كان في فرص كان في فرص متاحه وهذا الشيء
انت ما كان متحقق في قطاعات همم اخرى
والفرص هذه هي اللي ساهمت همم في بناء
قدرات همم
الدبلوماسيات في وزاره الخارجيه لانه في
حفله للمشاركه
لها الفرصه للعمل على ملفات مهمه وحساسه
ولولا دعم القيادات في وزاره الخارجيه على
راسها طبعا سمو الوزير فيصل بن فرحان ما
وصلنا للي وصلنا اليه لولا دعم قياده
المملكه اااه ورؤيه المملكه ومستهدفاتها
في مجالاتمكين المراه وازاحه الفرصه لها
لشغل هذه المناصب وسعي اصل الوصول الى
مستويات ان شاء الله باذن الله اعلى واعلى
ايضا ما كان شفنا كل هذه انماذج شكرا لك
وفيصل شرفتينا ونورتينا
لك شكرا لك
شكرا لكم
محمد الديني وفي الهندسه الصوتيه محمد
الحسن وفي الاشراف على الانتاج رزان
احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
اللي انطلق واستمر بدعمكم والدليل هذه
الحلقه اللي كانت همم 100% بدعم وتنسيق
احد اصدقاء
اللي قابل الضيفه في مكان عام همم على طول
تراسل معنا قال وش رايكم اني اقدم لها
دعوه باسمكم فقنا له توكل على الله وفتح
قناه التواصل وبهذه الطريقه كسبنا همم
حاجه الضيفه وضيوف كثر نتيجه دعم واهتمام
وهمم ترشيح اصدقاء سقراط فلا تحرمونا من
دعمكم في وصف الحلقه هيكون موجود ايميل
ورابط لترشيح الضيوف اللي عندكم وصول لهم
اللي ما عندكم وصول لهم هذول اللي غالبا
احنا قاعدين يعني نحاول معهم ثلاث تشيلهم
لكن يهمنا الضيوف اللي عندكم قدره ساعدونا
نوصل له مره ثانيه شكرا لكل اصدقاء
[موسيقى]